[Música]
[Aplausos]
algunos de vosotros queréis un vaso de
agua os adelanto que es agua no potable
algún voluntario y si hay algún
voluntario también decirle que detrás
tengo más vasos preparados y es que
veréis estoy convencida de que nadie se
bebería ese vaso de agua porque todos
sabemos que beber agua no potable es
perjudicial para nuestra salud
sin embargo fijaros 4 de cada 5 de
nosotros estamos respirando todos los
días
aire no saludable
os voy a decir una regla es una regla
que quizás además os pueda servir en un
momento de supervivencia es la regla del
3 es una regla que dice que en invierno
podemos estar tres semanas sin comer
tres días sin beber y solo tres minutos
sin respirar de hecho muchos de vosotros
quizás sepáis que más o menos bebemos
unos dos litros de agua al día
y de aire cuántos litros de aire
respiramos
el 3 5 y 6 litros al minuto es decir
respiramos entre 7200 y 8 mil 600 de
litros de aire al día
según la organización mundial de la
salud 42 millones de personas murieron
por muerte prematura causas prematuras
debido a la contaminación del aire en el
2016 4,2 millones de personas
de esos 42 millones 300 mil eran niños
menores de 5 años y aún así no hacemos
nada hay mucha gente que ya empieza a
hacer algo para que esa calidad del aire
y yo me incluyo dentro de ellos sea cada
vez mejor pero aún así no hacemos nada
la mayoría no hacemos nada asumimos que
tenemos que respirar este aire no
saludable os voy a dar otra cifra en
este caso es una fecha que es el 1 de
agosto el 1 de agosto además de un día
en el que seguro que todos muchos
estábamos de vacaciones este año en el
2018 se celebró ese día que tiene ese
nombre tan raro
o versión de qué quiere decir eso es lo
que quiere decir es que el 1 de agosto
como humanidad nos habíamos consumido
todos los recursos naturales que el
planeta puede generar en el año
esta es una fecha que se lleva midiendo
desde hace tiempo y año tras año ese día
se va adelantando hasta tal punto que
según el banco mundial y la población
que se tiene establecida para el 2050
en el 2050 necesitaremos tres planetas
al año al ritmo de consumo que estamos
teniendo
mirar yo llevo muchos años más de 13
luchando por el cambio climático por la
calidad del aire y la verdad es que
todavía cada vez que alguien habla de si
existe o no o cambio climático lo que
existe es destrucción del planeta
estamos destruyendo planeta
y llevo muchos años trabajando y también
os puedo decir que lo que estoy viendo
es que la única solución está en
nuestras manos
somos los únicos que podemos hacer algo
no quiero tampoco solo daros problemas
hay que buscar soluciones así que os voy
a pedir que hagáis un ejercicio conmigo
es un ejercicio voluntario es además un
ejercicio que me enseñó mi hermano que
también a su modo está cambiando el
mundo y que me gustaría además
reconocerlo y fijaros me quedo con esta
palabra que luego volveré a ella y que
me encanta porque es de esas palabras
que se escriben igual al derecho que al
revés porque cuanto más reconocemos a
los demás ese reconocimiento luego
vuelve
pero bueno siguiendo con el ejercicio
que solitario os voy a pedir además no
tenéis ni que levantar
que durante 10 segundos que además yo
contaría y os avisaré cuando el tiempo
termina pongáis vuestras manos lo más
próximas a entre sí sin llegar a tocarse
no pueden tocarse y durante esos diez
segundos os voy a pedir que lo único que
hagáis sea sentir vuestras manos y el
tiempo comienza ya
bueno antes de nada gracias por haber
sido tan partícipes veréis llevo
haciendo bastante tiempo ya este
ejercicio y cuando termina el ejercicio
y pregunto qué es lo que habéis sentido
la mayoría la mayoría la gran mayoría
dice que nada
y eso es imposible porque nuestras manos
y están hechas para sentir y es el
sentido del tacto tenemos 5 incluso
dicen que 6 sentidos más sentimos con
todo nuestro cuerpo que para eso es piel
sentimos con el corazón sentimos con la
cabeza que es ese sentido común que a
veces es el menos común de los sentidos
tenemos a esta sentido del humor y sin
embargo la mayoría contesta que no ha
sentido nada
y es que nos están acostumbrando a no
sentir
no se están acostumbrando a que si vemos
algo que no escuchamos algo que no nos
gusta vemos algo que no nos gusta o
tenemos algo que decir quién nos
sintamos
nos están acostumbrando a no sentir
decía walter riso la vida no tiene
sentido se la das tu con lo que hagas
con lo que te apasione con tus ilusiones
tú construyes el universo a tu medida
pues tenemos que construir no solo el
universo también el planeta ya esta
frase yo le añado que construimos con
nuestras decisiones
y es que creerme constantemente estamos
sintiendo pero creerme constantemente
estamos decidiendo es más somos los que
tenemos el poder de decidir
os voy a explicar un poco cómo funciona
la economía hoy en día este es nuestro
modelo económico lineal que ya está
demostrado que no funciona cogemos
recursos naturales generamos un producto
y de ese producto finalmente termina
siendo un residuo no os voy a contar
porque estamos gracias hoy en día a los
medios de comunicación viendo qué es lo
que está causando todos esos residuos
que estamos generando pero esta es el
modelo económico lineal que es
insostenible no solo para el planeta
también para nosotros que habitamos en
él
ahora y yo doy clases a mis alumnos doy
clases de logística y sostenibilidad y a
mis alumnos incluso ya les estoy
introduciendo el concepto no solo de
economía circular sino de logística
circular
buscamos ese ciclo completo buscamos el
esos residuos y poder volver a
meterlos en ese círculo de manera quien
necesitemos menos recursos naturales y
está bien está bien que empecemos ya a
que las organizaciones que generan un
producto empiecen a ver ya diseñar su
proceso pensando precisamente en eso no
en lo limitado que son esos recursos
naturales y el impacto que tienen en
todos nosotros esos residuos
pero veréis
desde mi punto de vista corremos el
peligro de volver a equivocarnos si no
empezamos a pensar qué es lo que esas
organizaciones no solo hacen en su
proceso productivo sino que es lo que
hacen cuando están haciendo ese producto
cómo tratan a sus empleados cómo tratan
a sus clientes cómo tratan al planeta
cómo tratan a la sociedad yo a esto es
lo que le llamo la economía esférica
porque
porque no todo vale no sólo sirve el
decir evito recursos naturales y evito
impacto en el medio ambiente tenemos que
empezar a premiar a aquellas
organizaciones que además cuiden de su
entorno local de sus empleados de sus
proveedores de sus clientes de la
sociedad y eso y creerme que llevo
muchos años trabajando en
responsabilidad social corporativa y
suelen decir que que si todo emana del
ceo de la compañía todo el despliegue y
la política emana hacia toda la empresa
os digo no es cierto
el feo hace lo que su cliente le pide si
vosotros como clientes empezáis a
decidir sintiendo y con sentido de
responsabilidad que es lo que empezáis a
adquirir dar por hecho que las
organizaciones empezarán a adaptarse a
vuestras necesidades ya vuestras
condiciones
cualquiera de nosotros podemos empezar a
decidir con nuestra decisión de compra
el premiar a organizaciones que lo estén
haciendo bien con todo este concepto
global
podemos tener un pacto y un alcance como
consumidor lo podemos tener como
ciudadano lo podemos tener como empleado
como parte de una organización pero
creerme que todos nosotros todos los
días estamos tomando decisiones que
pueden hacer que cambie el mundo
y a esas organizaciones que tengan esa
visión 360 esa economía esférica
aplicada a su modelo de negocio hay que
reconocérselo
porque si les hacemos brillar brillarán
iluminarán el camino y otros querrán
seguirle y eso es lo positivo que todos
queramos brillar
seamos ciudadanos pero aplicándose a
desobediencia inteligente empecemos a
repensar nuestro modelo de negocio
empecemos a repensar nuestra forma de
consumo empecemos realmente a repensar
que estamos haciendo porque lo estamos
haciendo que vamos a conseguir con ello
seamos desobedientes inteligentes y
seamos conscientes de que el poder lo
tenemos nosotros mirar este es un dibujo
que hizo mi hija cuando tenía seis años
es mi empresa que también he montado de
movilidad compartía el trabajo y cuando
se lo conté ella lo tuvo claro un logo
dos chicas que somos las que hemos
creado la empresa y vas a limpiar el
aire de malos humos a crear buen rollito
con amor y demás y relaciones entre las
personas que estamos perdiendo y ahorrar
tiempo una niña de seis años esta
generación lo tiene claro pero lo tiene
claro porque lo tiene que ver de ejemplo
qué vais a hacer vosotros no os pido que
creéis una empresa no os pido que solo
los cambies el mundo
pero y esto es una coincidencia
ecoembes que es una organización que se
dedica al reciclado de envases y también
al ecodiseño este año ha creado una
campaña que dice reciclar 6 latas
y evitarás equivale a evitar la emisión
de un tubo de escape durante 10 minutos
fijaros ecoembes esa economía circular y
sin embargo no se está hablando de esa
calidad del aire que comentábamos
cualquiera de nosotros insisto estamos
decidiendo tenemos capacidad para con
nuestro poder de decisión de compra
decidir si premio o no a aquellas
organizaciones que tienen impacto en mi
ciudad que tiene un impacto positivo en
el planeta que tiene un impacto positivo
en los empleados
solo nosotros haremos que sea eso lo que
se prioriza y aquellas que no lo están
haciendo bien empiecen a hacerlo
recordar
el poder está en vuestras manos tomando
decisiones sintiendo y con sentido
decía eduardo galiano mucha gente
pequeña y grande en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas pueden cambiar
el mundo
seamos esos superhéroes para nuestros
hijos que vean qué es lo que tenemos que
hacer y que empecemos a enseñarles cuál
es el modelo productivo y de consumo que
queremos si realmente queremos tener un
planeta
antes preguntaba quién de vosotros
compra en internet que levante la mano y
levantaba muy pocos ahora ya es raro
casi todo el mundo compra por internet a
la pregunta que suelo hacer es quien
compra comida por internet y cada vez
hay más
pues os digo empezar como consumidores
no a premiar tanto la comodidad
sino a premiar como antes decíamos
el que alguien lo haga bien
el que cuide de ese planeta el impacto
que mi decisión de compra tiene incluso
la exclusividad no tanto el tener por
tener o comprar por comprar aquel que
hoy en día está comprando un enchufe por
tres euros
y no se da cuenta de que el coste de
sacar ese material que no deja de ser
recursos naturales que se agotan la
fabricación la manipulación el embalaje
el transporte hasta que te llega a tu
casa por tres euros
si alguien no empieza a pensar que
quizás en toda esa cadena de valor se
están perdiendo o explotando a parte de
los que forman esa cadena de valor para
que ese enchufe llega a nuestra casa
pensar tomar decisiones sintiendo y con
sentido
a esos superhéroes para vuestros hijos
para vuestros amigos para vosotros
mismos porque creerme la pieza clave
sois vosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a mí